let's briefly talk about microorganisms
and the microbial community now that
we've seen
all of this information kind of from a
high level
what are we trying to study actually
okay so the question is is the r code
used for each step of the pipeline shown
available
no
not all of the code that you just saw
was an r
some of the code was
written in c some of it was
scripts and bash some of it was in r and
some of it was in python so it's really
a combination of different types of
codes that were put together in a single
workflow and that workflow in the end
produces these outputs which are either
files or interactive outputs
but the focus of the program will
primarily be on how to use a lot of
those different standard steps as well
as some coding in r so the majority of
the coding that we'll do will be in r
hopefully that answers your question
so let's uh briefly talk about
microorganisms and the microbial
community
what are we trying to study and how are
we going to be able to study this
community right why is it new and and
why is it useful
so the connection between disease and
microorganisms has been established
already in the 1800s and already towards
the end of the 19th century laboratory
methods for growing microorganisms in a
lab culture were developed helping
characterize them with staining these
studies provided important information
about bacteria function in isolation
however it was soon apparent that most
microorganisms don't live as individuals
but live in complex communities
and today we know that microorganisms as
they are called microbiota can be very
different in different places because
they form a stable community
and so one of the efforts of the
community that studies the microbiome is
to try to characterize both what is
healthy establish a baseline
and how do we measure deviation from
that healthy condition
so here you can see
that the number of studies
has been
exponentially increasing from the time
that these methods were introduced and
today we have a pretty good sense of
these different established communities
in the human body for example so here
you can see some
typical members of the microbiota in the
mouth
skin and other parts of the body and
here you can see the number of studies
of published research papers on human
microbiota now the majority of these
studies focus exclusively on the
bacteria but the microbiome actually
includes bacteria
as well as others other members of the
community including the virum which as
you know bacteriophages are important
members of that bacterial community that
regulate the composition
can infect bacteria bacteria fights them
off so
they do form kind of they do influence
each other
as well as archaea
and
other members as well so when you think
of the microbiome it's really all of the
microorganisms but when we will study
the types of analyses that we will
perform we'll focus on one of them and
typically it's going to be the bacteria
now in different parts of the body there
are different
numbers of bacterial species and in many
cases you will find an association
between the environment that they live
in
and the community that they form for
example
acidity levels um access to oxygen and
things like that are important factors
that actually determine uh how this
community evolves and is one of the
reasons
why we cannot just isolate a lot of
these individuals
to study them in a lab because we would
have to recreate the exact conditions
where they grow and those conditions are
in part dependent on the composition of
the microbiome so it's very difficult to
extract the microbiome and actually
reproduce it in a lab even though some
attempts are being made
so
uh typically when we think of the
microbiome we think of the gut and the
the digestion part of how the microbiome
functions but many other communities are
also as important for example
we can talk about the skin right so on
the skin surprisingly even though we
wash our skin all the time
we apply different things to our skin
these bacteria form a very stable
community and the reason is because
of course there are pores and the
bacteria
populate the pores as well as live in
different cracks between the skin cells
and so as a result
we can see that bacteria fungi and
viruses form a stable community that
starts interacting with the epithelium
in our skin
and that is why some of these uh studies
focused on the skin microbiome are
importantly uh
importantly uh are very important for
understanding
of how to treat diseases and how
potentially these bacterial communities
could be interrupted so to study a lot
of this many different international
projects have been started and those
include the nih human microbiome project
the british gut project the american gut
projects the different kinds of gut
projects
micro rosetta initiative there's even a
project for studying the microbiome in
space
through the nasa
consortium called gene lab
as well as different types of clinical
studies involving the microbiome like
the gut microbiome sub study for cancer
prevention or alzheimer's gut microbiome
project or the nurses health study
so a lot of interesting data sets have
been reposited on in the public domain
as a result of these consortia
and we will go through some of these
examples in this program using them as
case studies to really understand what
kinds of questions are people asking and
what kinds of information can we obtain
for example about the individuals that
are being studied the microbiome effects
on human health as well as many other
applications of the microbiome
so
let's go now and talk a little bit more
about where this data comes from so we
talked about the microbiome we talked
about where we want to get to how is
this data generated
so the way this data is generated
is using what's called metagenomic
sequencing and so to understand the
process we'll kind of go through the
history of metagenomic sequences and
exactly what is being sequenced
and then that will explain a lot of the
things in the metagenomic sequence
analysis and our ability to annotate and
interpret the results that we just saw
so we'll talk a lot here about what's
called 16s amplicon sequencing and it's
a technique that was developed because
the 16s
ribosomal rna gene
is an established gene that has a common
function across many different types of
bacterial species
and
the variation
has specific
indications for the levels of taxonomy
so the 16s ribosomal rna sequencing is
also low cost flexible and it provides
us a long enough read
that can actually answer a lot of the
questions that we have about the
microbond composition
why is that
the reason is because here you can see
the 16s ribosomal rna gene so it folds
into the structure and has what are
called different regions so these v1 to
v9 are the different regions
and
the full gene is approximately 1500 base
pairs long
but it also has specific conserved
regions these regions that we see poking
out are conserved and those are between
30 and 100 base pairs long
now in between you have variable regions
and then you have conserved regions and
so the
databases that we will use to annotate
where these reads came from
actually contain those sequences already
annotated by the strains of bacteria
that they come from
one of those
databases is called the silva database
we'll use that extensively but also
there are others like green genes rdp
and the ncbi national center for
biotechnology information also contains
that as well now there have been
publications that have compared how this
is
how these databases
annotate the different taxa using the
16s ribosomal rna gene sequence and it
comes out that two major things are
important number one
uh
when everything is driven by users
there's a lot of noise because maybe
there are some
you know opposite views of which taxes
that came from but also because someone
needs to validate and clean up and
constantly kind of interact with the
data to make sure it's up to date and it
turns out that silva is one of those
repositories that is most actively
supported reviewed and validated and so
that's why in a lot of cases we'll see
people use the silva database to
annotate their metagenomic data
now how is stacks and normal
classification actually perform so we
have here the ribosomal rna so the
ribosome consists of two parts the
larger part and the smaller and they are
called the subunit so we have the 30s
ribosomal subunit and the gene that
encodes for that subunit is the 16s
ribosomal rna gene
that gene
could be amplified and to amplify so we
extract the dna from the microbiome from
the actual biological sample
and then we need to amplify some target
region because we cannot sequence the
full 1500 uh base pair long
sequence
not with the luminous sequencers at
least but other sequencers could do that
but with illumina sequencer sequencing
which is the most reliable
and cost effective in this case
you can see that the primer sequence has
to be designed for specific target
regions
now
different combinations of these hyper
variable regions are used for the actual
sequencing sometimes it's just v3
sometimes just b4 sometimes v3 and v4
together sometimes you can add another
one of these hyper variable regions it
really depends on the level of taxonomy
that you would like to use
and the ability to amplify and then
sequence those reads
what essentially happens is that with
this amplicon approach if the less you
amplify the less of your data is going
to be used so the less information will
you be able to expect from your data a
comparison between the full 16s ribosome
rna gene for example sequenced with
nanopore or with pac bio compared to
illumina which would only use one of the
hyper variable regions is that you lose
about 50
of your data so you get 50 percent more
information if you sequence the full
gene
obviously variation in combinations of
the hypervariable regions also play a
role
but what you can do as a result
is uh actually look at the different
levels right so the
more hypervariable regions you have the
deeper you can go in the taxonomy so
instead of just looking at the species
which obviously bacteria is just one
or sorry kingdom instead of going
through the kingdom bacteria is just the
kingdom
you can go all the way to the species if
you sequence everything if you only
sequence some for example two maybe you
can only go to order or family level and
not any deeper
but essentially then you can look at the
body for example and
analyze the composition right so
proportions of different types of
taxonomies and compare them between
individuals between groups of
individuals or find associations between
individuals or microbiota and some
phenotype
so this will be the data preparation the
biological data preparation and this
would be the analysis now this is just
based on the sequence data what other
types of data can be used for
understanding not only what the
composition is but also importantly we
want to understand the function
so for sequencing dna based approaches
like 16s ribosomal rna or its gene
sequencing could be used its just
another gene that is used for
assigning taxonomy
but also we can use meta transcriptomics
or full metagenomics so full
metagenomics right here
means that we're trying to not only
select a gene for taxonomy but we would
like to then assemble everything that we
sequence into full genomes
that's a challenge because we don't know
all of the genomes so there is not a
comprehensive database to say these are
all the possible genomes let's just find
those
we're always expecting to find new
genomes and because they live in a
community we expect to be some drift uh
you know genetic drift a recombination
and other types of interactions that we
really cannot predict and so that makes
whole genome metagenomics challenging
another approach is to try to understand
well what genes are being expressed
again here the problem is we don't know
all the genes that could be present so
how do we measure their abundance right
how do we denoise this data and so
that is why the majority of the studies
are still relying on 16s ribosomal rna
however more and more whole genome
metagenomics is being performed and even
some metatranscriptomics is being done
today as well
in addition to that we can study the
proteins and metabolites that are being
produced
and that gives us another important
insight into not only what is being uh
done in the community but how is that
community interacting with the host
and to do that
ultimately we would like to integrate
all of this information together and
that brings us to systems medicine
approach or systems biology approach to
be able to understand how all of this
information between the types of
bacteria the types of viruses the types
of hosts that they are in and the
different impacts of variables like diet
drugs and other things can play a role
in this complex system
so we won't go all the way into that
portion of it of how to integrate all
that data but we will definitely give
you a good sense of how you can get
started with metagenomics and then
hopefully that will give you enough
tools to continue and study other
methods as well that we will also
potentially cover in other programs
so let's talk now about some practical
examples and case studies that we're
going to review in this program
one interesting repository is the
american gut sample so this is a project
that was started first of all as a
research study but then was crowd funded
and really offered to anyone who would
like to participate to be able to
understand several different things
first of all i would like to understand
about my own gut sample
what is in it what are the what are the
proportions and and what is the taxonomy
and maybe something is known about these
specific strains or speciesism in my
body
another important insight is that i
could compare my microbiome compared to
other microbiomes of other individuals
and since i know something about those
individuals for example what kinds of
diets they have or what kinds of
activity they uh do throughout the week
i could then understand maybe where i
stand in terms of the comparison so here
this large dot represents this
individual and the little dots represent
some of the other members of this
project
and here the same way
so here
this project
the data is accessible online so what
we'll do is we'll actually take some of
the metadata and here you can see just a
sample comparison that we will do where
we will take individuals that exercise
rarely exercise regularly and we will
try to extract their data using the
sample id
and process this data to compare them to
each other and we'll ask the question
does exercise in fact have any effect on
the microbiome composition
another example project that we'll talk
about is the skin microbiome how do we
study inflammation acne causes
inflammation of course skin rashes how
can we actually look at the different
types of inflammation caused by these
microbial communities and just find
associations right so again what's
important here is that we're dealing
with noisy data
a lot of the information that we need is
missing and when we ask these questions
we ask pretty general questions um and
and then if we want to go beyond the
general questions then we want to
actually functionally validate that what
we are saying
is
true
a lot of times we cannot perform those
types of experiments on individuals so
what we'll do is we'll look at a mouse
study
that actually tries to isolate the
impact that the micro microbiome
composition plays
in the relationship between obesity
and anxiety
because really today when you look at
the literature that uh describes
microbial communities you will see that
a lot of that
is
you know potentially very impactful but
the question is you know is that really
true right so there's a lot of
microbiome
you know theoretically could be involved
in almost anything but how do you know
that it's microbiome and not anything
else